hey this is dr. John Delaney with the
Ramsey Network starting this new crazy
YouTube's channel we've have some other
videos here but we're now cranking it
out and we're running and gunning over
the next few months we're gonna be
talking about mental health issues
depression anxiety ADHD relationship
stuff what's going on in your head
what's going on in your heart what's
going on in your marriage and your
relationships with your parents with
your crazy kids with all bit of lock in
the house with your teachers education
all of it man we're gonna be we're gonna
be digging in deep with this stuff so if
you want to ask me questions direct and
I'll respond to you here on the show you
can email me at ask John at Ramsey
solutions com we're gonna be taking live
calls and we'll have some video feeds in
here so it's gonna be all cool thing
make sure you subscribe it's gonna be
rad so I just did an event with dr. les
parrot and Rachael Cruz called the money
marriage and I added mind event they
just let me tag along as kind of the
opener and it was super rad super cool
thousands of people across the country
kind of blew us all out of the water how
many people signed up for this event but
one of the things I talked about was
this idea that we think in pictures and
we speak in words and man I got a lot of
feedback of people want me to dig into
that little bit more so here's what we
talked about today this idea I stole it
from William Glasser he's one of the the
preeminent psychologists actually is a
psychiatrist he passed away several
years ago he's a brilliant mind a
wonderful thinker and he really
distilled all the mental health crazy
mumbo-jumbo down to a couple of finite
things one of them is this we think in
pictures but we speak in words and what
happens is we end up talking past each
other all the time I gave an example on
the show the other night about
relationships in having a date here's
another example I'm how it plays out in
my house let's say for instance my wife
Sheila calls and she says hey man we got
to talk tonight dude and you know you
get that feeling like you're like that's
what I do we sit down and she kind of
lays out hey here's who you've been in
the last few months I'm saying this cuz
I love you but I need you to step up and
be a better husband and I hear her she's
right man I kind of crummy at this
husband thing I'm still trying to figure
it out after almost 20 years but I'm
like you're right I mean it and so I
hear the words be a better husband and
I'm down I'm gonna step up and do this
and so before I go to bed I email
several of my friends who are leaders at
colleges across the country and I just
say hey can I pick up another adjunct
professor job can I teach a counseling
class for you can I teach an education
graduate class for you and that's before
I go to bed and the next morning I set
my alarm for 4:45 I get up I do my quick
morning routine I do my gratitude
journal my prayers and then I'm out I go
to the gym it we're all pandemic
lockdown right now so I can't go to the
gym but I'm out in the neighborhood
working out and then I get home and it's
breakfast time that's her world man and
she she's my wife's so gifted at
hospitality at setting up an environment
where people can connect with one
another that's her world so I stay out
of the kitchen I stay out of the table I
hug my kids i high-five her I just make
sure I'm clear of her space because when
she said be a better husband what I
heard was did you need to make some more
money you're kind of letting the old
body go so you got to get you gotta
start working out man this is getting
ridiculous and I need you to give me my
space and we're we miss each other is
her picture her idea of what a better
husband looks like if somebody who's
more present he wears sweatpants and
quits thinking about their body all the
time because they're vain and he will
just sit down and have a cup of coffee
hanging out with the family in the
morning and so I heard be a better
husband she said be a better husband but
our pictures of what a better husband is
we just missed we started asking each
other every single morning hey what's
your picture of today look like or if we
have an event or a dinner or a video
shoot or a birthday party or a fishing
trip whatever it may be that's become
common language that we use multiple
times every day hey what's your picture
of dinner look like tonight hey we have
this event with Ramsey on Friday night
what's the picture of that for me and
that way she's not having to worry about
all week what she's gonna wear or I'm
not having to worry about all week about
what time we're gonna show up I just
know because we then get on the same
page on the same page about what the
picture of the event is gonna look like
and so my challenge to you to the people
you interact with and you can do this
with your parents you can do this with
your workmates with your bosses with
your wife with your husband whoever in
your life it's just instead of saying
hey be a better husband I need
step up here at work I need you to be a
better coach hey kids
I need you just to quit me in idiots
stop being so lame dude quit sucking
look whatever the thing is instead of
doing that just be real clear and say
hey here's my picture of what tonight's
gonna look like my picture of after the
Little League game tonight is y'all
gonna go home take your bath you're
gonna go I'll go to bed not we get home
we gotta hustle kids that doesn't mean
anything to a seventh grader right so
here's the deal we think in pictures and
we speak in words and my challenge to
you is start speaking in pictures start
painting a picture for the people around
you to be more clear and concise and
direct gets everybody on the same page
and you're all going the same direction
this is dr. John Bologna
don't forget ask John at Ramsey
solutions.com
I love to hear from you it will answer
some of your calls on this channel or
I'm gonna be calling you myself and
we'll be taking some of the calls on
this channel we're gonna be in the
neighborhoods we're gonna be all over
the place
probably not as sounds cool probably sit
in this chair most the time but we're
gonna talk about mental health
relationships all of it parenting
schools
I don't know fireman we're talking about
fireman getting ripped cuz clearly look
at this look at this all right I will
see you soon take care